oh yeah he's into it check out prince
george who is all smiles as he makes a
surprise appearance on day 14 of
wimbledon marking his first time at the
games the eight-year-old set in between
his dad prince william and mom kate
middleton and the royal box during the
men's finals
looking snazzy george is dressed in a
smart blue suit which is the perfect
compliment to his mom kate's outfit the
duchess whose style has been on full
display during the annual sporting event
looks effortlessly chic in a black and
white polka dot dress which she pairs
with sunglasses
meanwhile william looks handsome as he
wears a light brown jacket and blue
pants
george who was an avid sports fan is
full of expressions as he watches the
intense match between novak djokovic and
nick curios there are even moments where
the young royal is seen asking his mom
and dad questions about the game and
take a look at this sweet shot where
kate is seen motioning george in her
hubby to wave at her parents carol and
michael middleton who receded a few
rolls away kate and george also made
their way around the venue and kate
introduced her son to the working staff
inside before they met up with william
who greeted them with a kiss prior to
taking their seats
george's debut at wimbledon may remind
those of when his father william made
his debut in 1991 alongside his mother
princess diana during the women's finals
[Music]
prince george's latest appearance comes
after he attended his great-grandmother
queen elizabeth's platinum jubilee
celebrations where his sister princess
charlotte corrected his posture on the
palace balcony it all happened when they
played the national anthem god saved the
queen and george made the mistake of
putting his hand on the balcony's ledge
that's when the seven-year-old nudged
her big bro's arm seemingly telling him
to fix his posture
[Music]
someone else who stole the show during
the platinum jubilee celebrations was
george and charlotte's little brother
prince louis the four-year-old made
headlines for publicly acting out while
his mom kate was speaking to him
that was just one of the few cheeky
moments that et's royal expert katie
nichol was there to witness
on the palace balcony william and kate's
son louie adorably covered his ears and
started yelling as the military jets in
a 70 formation flew overhead the
four-year-old had the best facial
expressions as he waved wildly to the
crowd and chatted to his
great-grandmother the queen
his antics had his sister charlotte
actually scolding him at one point
telling him to pay attention
[Music]